we begin with breaking news want to take
you to London where police have shot a
man after several people were stabbed on
London Bridge police say they are in the
early stages of an incident there and
that a man has been detained a white
vehicle was seen parked on the bridge as
police cleared the area and ambulances
arrived on the scene London Bridge was
the scene of a 20-17 attack when
so-called Islamic state inspired
attackers drove in two people on that
very same bridge and then went on a
stabbing spree killing eight people all
right this is very much a developing
story that we are in the midst of let's
go to Charlotte Potts who is monitoring
developments for you first of all what
have you learned well we now know that
police have confirmed that they
responded to a stabbing at 158 p.m. so
just over a little over an hour ago on
London Bridge and it appears BBC
journalist was walking by it appears
that several people have been fighting
and shouting at one man who was carrying
a knife there are several videos of
bystanders online that have been posted
on Twitter and other social media where
you can see this incident happening and
that the police have responded with
heavy weaponry coming onto the scene at
London Bridge and it appears that they
have shot the offender but they are also
reporting that one man has been detained
in this incident so London Bridge of
course the scene of the 2017 terror
attack in June where three men linked to
the Islamic state drove in two
pedestrians there and then went on to
Borough Market a tourism hot spot just
around the corner from London Bridge
stabbing dozens of people there so this
is something that is very familiar to
London authorities they know how to
respond and I've talked to several
people close that are at the moment in
the city of London
where all the big skyscrapers are
located banks and insurance buildings
and most of those buildings appear to be
on lockdown so that means nobody can go
in or out while the police is dealing
with this incident and we've also heard
from the London ambulance services that
are calling this a major incident and
that a number of people have been
injured they have confirmed so this is
what we know at this hour all right so
the area is in lockdown sealed off
I mean how on edge are people they are
really on edge London has seen a number
of terrorist attacks in 2017 smaller
ones afterwards in the years to follow
so now two years on this city is
extremely used to incidents incidences
like this extremely prepared and of
course very scared that a that that
major terrorist attacks like they
happened back then in 2017 could happen
again
so this is why the city is so prepared
I've mentioned all the buildings
downtown there in the City of London are
on lockdown and they've gone through
this in the past so they know how to
deal with it now the police were very
quick to respond we've been hearing and
also the ambulance services it is a city
that is really trained to deal with
these kind of incidences Charlotte Potts
reporting on that breaking story thank
you for the update